well just over two miles from here more
than 100 workers at the mayfield
consumer products factory were making
candles when a tornado
tore through the building at least eight
of them were killed workers say they
were told to huddle in a hallway which
was the strongest part of the building
as the storm approached many say they
saw the roof peel away and the walls
cave in
the company says eight other workers are
still missing our lead national
correspondent david begno is following
that story and is here with me and david
just to think that many of these workers
were there doing overtime working around
the clock to get these candles ready for
the holidays you know i interviewed the
ceo of the company and he said we have
eight people dead i said wait a minute
the governor said 80 to 100. how do you
only have eight there's a big
discrepancy here and he said well we
thought that many were dead because we
couldn't reach him
couldn't make a call and he said we
ended up over the next 24 36 hours
tracking them down and that's why the
apparent death toll is so much smaller
than what we were led to believe it
could be
you know just about as soon as we got
here within the first two to three hours
we started talking to survivors
who were tearfully telling us what it
was like to survive the tornado
and to then get out you're going to hear
from four of them now
they told us it was a tornado warning
coming and everybody needed to go for
shelters and all of a sudden everything
started caving in on everybody nobody
seen it coming this is barbara tate
she worked at the mayfield consumer
products factory for two years right
alongside her brother who was there when
the tornado hit and also got out alive
yes it was a lot of stuff to fail on us
but we we had a crowd
crowd like like like you know get on
your knees and everything crawl and try
because we couldn't move a certain way
or everything would fall on top of us
this is another survivor richard padilla
he joined other workers in a central
hallway the strongest part of the
building when the alarms sounded do you
need some help
he is still in so much pain after what
he experienced the ceiling
blows up
and a couple of seconds
after that
a wall
fall
above us
and then
we were in a position
very uncomfortable
with a lot of things over us
and then i finally saw somebody
who
was giving his hand to me
meet felicia lynn she had only been
working at the factory since september
and was also in that central hallway
when the roof was ripped off and the
walls collapsed my both leg was twisted
my arm is twisted to release my feet i
have to let go my two shoes there was a
small light in there so i climb up
myself
she limped out of the wreckage and
recorded this video you hear her
repeatedly saying thank you god for
saving me
but thank you for learning
she also credits this man nelson
gonzalez her supervisor for rescuing her
he was the one who helped to free her
legs so that she could get out i was
making sure that the people was next to
me
i wasn't going to leave them behind
i'm not going to let them down
they're my families as well
nelson and richard had recently moved
here from puerto rico they were looking
for work and the candle factory needed
seasonal workers
they were working the night shift along
with barbara and felicia
four of the 110 people inside that
factory when it got hit i closed my eyes
and all i see is people hollering and
screaming for him so i'm not doing good
at all
you're messing with a person when you
see that and you can't help anybody
you try to help yourself get out
you understand why miss barbara feels a
sense of guilt for not being able to
help more people listen nelson is headed
back to puerto rico today with his son
who worked the day shift and
is okay he wasn't there nelson said he's
not sure if he's coming back nor his
wife told him you could tell everybody
goodbye because i'm not letting you
go back the owner of the factory has
started a account a gofundme to raise
money and the owner of the factory has
given a hundred thousand dollars to get
a kick started to help the people what
so many people have gone through here
david bagno thank you